[Music]
hello patronage X Happy New Year so we
thought we'd do something very special
just for you patronage X now um we have
currently a little over 70 patrons right
now and but we've interacted with
there's a certain amount that we've
interacted with quite frequently and we
wanted to do a little a little song for
you guys you know it's it's super
meaningful all the rhymes will make
sense in my rapping yes and gonna tell
you a story about your lives that you
didn't even know happened yet but and
I've spent 3 weeks working on this I
didn't just write it six months to make
this we did we did we didn't leave the
house once no we got quite a quite a
good amount of people mention in this in
this little song we have here and
literally wrote it today music I was
like okay I'll write it today we
practiced maybe a couple of times and
yeah in my opinion it's a perfect
masterpiece and John and I are not
nervous at all about screwing this up
but [ __ ] it it's just for you guys
anyway let's let's have some fun John
get ready to kick it off whenever you
feel like it let me cut the camera to
make sure the mics working I change the
battery you got got loose monkey or
funky monkey it's stretched out monkey
let's do this
[Music]
let's kick it up with em castle pretty
redheaded little damsel Austin
Harrisville Bing Anna Faris's our
reactions fun expressions Juliana
Fletcher does get wet sir when she sees
the hump free and he humps for free
that's a rhyme about Johnny Christopher
American was caught [ __ ] out man
again
Nicholas Fehn Julian is not Ethiopian at
least I don't think so all well what do
I know
Terminator songs got a dick so long
Jason Dole in and money he'd be rolling
and a Ramirez look so delicious
he's buffer then though Wahlberg I'm
talking about house Heisenberg that's
more of a homophone rhyme whatever we're
short on time yes we are suspicious name
like Colin Schaefer a name that sounds
like a scary slasher Christopher a
pageant had sex with a hobbit and ate
chicken nuggets five for 20 Abdul Buddha
with goodies in vaginas
Heather Christopher is a wizard and
since she's British probably much Oxford
ello governor the Kyle Club a bench or a
loyal Richard ball the word gave us some
DVDs so he's also a give her thank you
it was a really sweet drawing to you by
the way thank you a girl named milena
blah blah blah sweetie that mixes go
haha Greg kiddo
Alexa give oral hell it's mutual hello
lb you're such a cutie who knows her
movies and chebika way he's okay it's
channels doing better than ours
don't be shy of the camera Chamberlain
Adelia
for you got great charisma Nawroz
Krishnan seems so calm had sex with a
corpse that was embalmed I'd say to
Erica Tuesday join us for a threesome
don't worry I'll pay I don't have the
money all the wild there's so much to
freestyle with a name like that
Lyle's here we go x-files totally
jumbled this totally humbled
after having Skyland his bank accounts
been fumbled j.t the man from huh y8
talks with us quietly yeah charismatic
Lee James Sagan's Russell beam pagan
eats a lot of bacon smoke cigarettes
with that indoor fragrance David Gandy
wrote you love me cancerous Lee we'll
actually don't because you actually beat
cancer sorry you shouldn't say that
David Gandy is super friendly with a
heart sincere he's super classy she's
Natalie Doran all the way from Ireland
come to California well starts cuddlin
she told me to watch a row now it's one
of my go-to shows JM Valente has a lot
to say
his words just spray may be a little
crazy he lives a Portugal said it's a
cerebral and a little cynical Kent
McKnight has smile so bright ANCA kick
our ass in an MMA fight also he loves
Star Trek has fine aspects Jack Daniels
in the morning yet never looks like a
wreck can't quite pinpoint Andrew Hayes
has a beautiful gaze watch this video
for days we love them always like I said
on Tuesday you could produce screenplays
yes you can and you Turpin and books to
be read and knowledge he absorbent I see
in Florida and my girl she's laughing
but I won't be fighting Kuzma ass he'll
be kicked in he's tall
[Music]
Tony McGwire has sexy attire suffer
worse attire and hair admire ladies look
out for the McGuire your mouth and
perspire when it fills with desire
jeff bearskin Peterson is a kingpin with
penis for skin but it digs so big it can
play the violin could've rhymed Peterson
with Native American or maybe even
Indian and what a made more sense for
him but I wanted to see him grin mat
beer kill the deer where the spirit out
into tears
have no fear mat beer moved to
California cuz ya bring us cheer smiles
from ear to ear
always so sincere does he actually like
us it's quite unclear confusing
well hello to Diego he'll smile will
pierce your heart like a sharpened arrow
he's like a combination of Superman
meets another like good-looking Superman
it's like Christopher Reeves is Henry
Cavill and Brandon Ralph combined a
little bit of James Dean it's not fair
we call it Lady Stark that's Rosa para
has lit such a spark like a badess like
Aria has a girl named Cassandra a
beautiful mexican-american hey Rosa para
if you're into necrophilia you can have
sex with John said body your name dried
with necrophilia I'm sorry top pledge of
the year here we go if I could hell I
should have sex with Jerry good come to
our neighborhood and sunny Holly
would and teach me what it's like living
in fatherhood he is the international
man of mystery an honorable man who's
also funny and to your son yousa get
tough gross scruff get rough and don't
forget to walk that's a very important
advice you sub well I hope you haven't
led after all that's been said man no
disrespect working on this project hope
you don't regret becoming a patron I
checked and no disrespect working on
this project hope you don't regret
becoming a patron eject
I think I think we were never once
offbeat no I think the whole time
fingers weren't sweating we I didn't
bumble on any words I think it's been a
very clear I think it was actually
perfect where one take wonders that's
what we are happy new year